since its release back in 2001
Microsoft's flagship console has had its
fair share of controller designs and
with the Xbox series X release right
around the corner here's a look back at
the history and evolution of the Xbox
controller the original Xbox controller
commonly referred to as the Duke made
its way to consumers hands in November
2001 while the original Xbox console was
overall a success for Microsoft's first
step into the gaming console market most
people were not exactly fans of the
controller's design at launch the
overall builder the controller was huge
to say the least and with a console that
was a monster in its own right housing
the entire system or even worse
traveling with it was a constant chore
the Juke was almost the same size as
some handheld systems at the time and
also exhibited some rather strange
design details like an unnecessarily
large Center logo and oval-shaped
buttons it is worth noting however that
the controller did helped pioneer the
indented analog sticks along with more
ergonomic left and right triggers making
shooters more enjoyable
after Gregg's about the excessive weight
and size of the original Xbox controller
Microsoft dialed it down a bit with its
second iteration with it being more lean
and ergonomically pleasing along with
the smaller build the updated design
shrank the logo moved the black and
white buttons to the bottom for easier
access and also brought back the rounded
button style the revised controller was
well received by the gaming community
and practically paved the way for future
Xbox controllers going forward four
years after the release of the original
Xbox Microsoft released the highly
anticipated Xbox 360 the next-gen
console did a 180 and ditched the dark
color scheme going with a predominantly
white and grey design this controller
had a more uniform body with very little
creases and lines to show where the
pieces fit together the new design also
allowed players different options on how
to power the controller with a removable
battery compartment in the back this
said the course for how Microsoft would
approach battery life for its future
designs as well as promotes an entirely
cordless user experience which was a big
selling point for consoles at the time
additional design changes also inked
the removal of the black and white
buttons in favour of adding bumper
buttons to the top left and right sides
of the controller this was also the
first time Microsoft made use of the
center logo which not only showed you
which player number you were but also
acted as a home button allowing you to
enter the consoles hub to use different
applications for the following seven
years other iterations of this specific
design didn't really make any major
changes other than adding a twistable 8
to 4-way d-pad and the color scheme okay
so it's not like the 4-way directional
pad ever really went away but after 11
years of using the 8 Way d-pad the Xbox
one for the first time introduced the
classic 4-way d-pad to its design other
than that the controller very much kept
the overall button layout similar to
that of its predecessor with some
additional tweaks including a redesign
for the controller's grips the
elimination of the protruding battery
pack and more ergonomic bumper and
trigger buttons later in 2015
Microsoft also adopted a more common
audio feature adding a 3.5 millimeter
audio jack which finally allowed gamers
to connect most of their preferred
gaming headsets directly into the
controller two years after the release
of the original Xbox one controller
Microsoft shifted gears to cater to a
more enthusiast driven audience with the
Xbox one elite controller shaded in
black and silver the metal infused Xbox
one elite was meant to be fully
customizable giving gamers an
opportunity to personalize their
controllers to better fit their
particular playstyle
this included interchangeable paddles
and analog sticks as well as hair
trigger locks customizable sensitivity
and button mapping while the elite was a
definite upgrade from the original Xbox
one controller it came at a high price
literally this device was bundled with
the upgraded Xbox one S consoles and had
very little difference to the original
Xbox one controllers with the exception
of updated texture grips and Bluetooth
capability allowing use as an
alternative to the wireless adapter when
pairing it to PC during the same year as
the release of the Xbox one elite
Microsoft began working on a controller
that would enable players with
disabilities even greater access to the
video games they already loved to play
the control consists of a slim
rectangular frame with two large buttons
that could be mapped to any fog
using the Xbox accessories app the new
device also included a large d-pad along
with the other buttons normally featured
on a standard Xbox one controller with
USB ports along with 19 3.5 millimeter
jacks that corresponds it to each button
trigger bumper and d-pad function the
adaptive controller ultimately opened
the door even further for multiple
assistive input devices to be connected
another noteworthy mention is that the
adaptive controller isn't Hardware
locked - strictly Xbox giving users the
opportunity to use it across any gaming
platform after the success of the elite
controller Microsoft doubled down on the
Xbox one elite and created the elite
series - with its already stacked resume
of customizable options the series -
took things a step further with
additional features like adjustable
tension thumbsticks shorter hair trigger
locks and Bluetooth connectivity giving
players even more freedom on how and
where they could utilize the new
controller the series - additionally
added three custom profile buttons which
allows players to quickly change between
play styles to better suit the type of
game they're currently playing which is
your favorite Xbox controller and why
don't forget for more on next-gen
including the Xbox series X keep your
eyes peeled to GameSpot